[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je vous dis que nous sommes capables
de voir avec la peau vous est ce qui
serait sûrement un petit sourire moqueur
et pourtant dans les années 70 le
neurologue paul baquiast états à
travailler sur la question
il en a même conclu qui est possible de
remplacer un sens par un autre en
l'occurrence le sens de la vue par le
sens du toucher
pour le démontrer da produit un
prototype de la taille d'un ivan cette
image montre le dispositif constitué
d'une caméra qui filme l'environnement
et d'un ordinateur qui transmet cette
information un fauteuil
le fauteuil est couvert de pitau qui
reproduisent l'image rap la peau du dos
l'utilisateur est capable de percevoir
les formes et les images nouvelles
formes de transmission un remplacement
du sens de la vue par le sens du toucher
comme vous pouvez le voir ce dispositif
est un peu encombrant en 2013 j'étais
encore au lycée et j'ai vu un thème pour
présenter des lunettes connectés elle
projetait directement les images sur la
rétine je me suis demandée cd possible
de faire la même chose sur la peau cette
idée de substitution de sens m'a
passionné et nous avons imaginé avec un
ami andré de fabrique un patch connectés
qui donnerait une version simplifiée de
l'environnement aux personnes aveugles
on peut se demander si ce type de
prothèse révolutionnera la vie des non
voyants 35 millions de personnes sont
aveugles dans le monde et on en compte
deux cent mille en france sachez que la
majorité d'entre eux ne le sont pas de
naissance il se pourrait qu'un jour vous
aussi vous deveniez non voyants je
travaille aux côtés de non voyants
et figurez-vous que de temps en temps
j'entends un gros choc
la première fois je fus surpris je suis
retournée et je compris que l'un d'eux
n'avait pas vu un mur un mur est un
grand obstacle
et pourtant ne va pas perçu vous me
direz que c'est normal qu'un aveugle ne
voit pas mais leur vie serait
révolutionner pouvait percevoir le monde
même en très basse qualité ne demande
pas de voir les nervures d'une feuille
dans un arbre et demande de voir l'arbre
pour ne pas se faire de bosses se
déplacer avec bien plus d'assurance dans
la rive en intérieur ou dans la nature
imaginer qu'un non voyant plus voir
comme sur cette image de 50 pixels sur
cent ne se considérait plus comme non
voyant l'image de type game boy est
amplement suffisante pour percevoir un
mur et même mieux que ça se déplacer
sans canne blanche le pape est composé
de picots qui a pris micro pression sur
la fois ils reproduisent les images à la
manière des pixels des pixels qui ne
sont que noir ou blanc comme sur les
premiers écrans de télévision l'idée
n'est pas de reproduire ou rita lire
parfaitement le sens de la vue ce serait
formidable mais personne en est capable
en fait cette vision de 50 sur 100 que
nous sommes en train de reproduire est
une prouesse technique
comment remplacer ce sens si technique
les sens sont des domaines d expertise
pour eux cei vous différencier le goût
d'une pomme de celui d'un oignon aussi
surprenant que ça puisse paraître
seul un tiers d'entre vous on est
capable pour faire l'expérience ou
bander les yeux bouche et le nez et
croquer dans l'es2 le goût et l'odorat
100-200 différents pourtant ils
fonctionnent ensemble pour donner une
seule et même information
une pomme aura un goût plus prononcé si
vous voyez santé vous savez que c'est
une pomme devant nous limiter notre
solution aux premiers tests ou
l'apprentissage un réel impact
notre sens où un incroyable talent et
seulement six mois d'entraînement
par exemple vous connaissez le braille
l'écriture en relief pour les
non-voyants et bien lire du brave
demande un grand entraînement avez vous
déjà essayé de dire du braille sur une
boîte de médicaments
je vous demande pas si vous avez réussi
car c'est totalement impossible sans
d'entraînement si ce soir chez vous vous
plier à l'exercice
vous ne serez pas dire où sont les
points toutes nouvelles compétences
acquises et maîtrisée par l'homme a
nécessité une phase d'apprentissage une
activité contre intuitive et très
difficile peut devenir aussi facile que
respirer faire du vélo par exemple qui
parmi vous se souvient des difficultés
que vous avez eu au début pour ne pas
tomber faut tourner le guidon direction
nous penchons au début cette activité
nous demandaient 100 % notre
concentration et maintenant cela ne nous
demande pas plus que de marcher notre
dispositif n'a pas de raison de se
comporter différemment
sur cette image en noir et blanc vous
êtes capable de percevoir le relief
pourtant vous ne voyez que la différence
de lumière sur une image
hâte d'être capable de le voir car vous
avez vu tout pour lui
mais les évident que le noir et blanc ne
serait pas adapté aux personnes nées
sens la vue c'est pour cette raison que
nous sommes basés sur notre manière de
représenter l'environnement sur cette
image vous être capable de voir les
profondeurs qu'une zone et noir plus est
loin voyant ou aveugles sommes capables
de percevoir le relief donc les abeilles
natif ou non pourront se déplacer sans
encombre vous souvenez de la photo du
dispositif de la taille d'un minivan et
bien si un dispositif miniature comme
sur cette image de paul bacquet et a été
réalisable et surtout 100% fonctionnelle
la vie quotidienne des non voyants ne
serait plus la même
si un jour la grosse caméra de ménage
une micro caméra sur une aide connecter
un ordinateur de la taille d'une clé usb
batterie de la taille d'un téléphone
portable
ce rêve deviendrait possible bienvenue
en 2019 ce jour est arrivé il ya
quelques mois premier prototype complet
a été fabriqué pour les essais cliniques
nous avons associé à des jeux un jeu de
morpion est un jeu que nous avons appelé
des chiffres et pas de l'être rapidement
les têtes sont des buts et des non
voyants sa base un premier protocole
nous avions prédit de choses les non
voyants seraient bien plus douée carré
en ce sens du toucher plus fins et les
jeunes réussir est bienvenu que les
moins jeunes
nous étions certains que ces hypothèses
être confirmée par les résultats sont
pourtant avérés complètement fausse à
notre échelle de test des voyants et
c'est mieux que des non voyants et les
jeunes donnaient exactement les mêmes
résultats que les manger lors d'un test
je me suis excusé face à une
utilisatrice
ces résultats étaient tous parfaits dès
le début pour moi ça signifiait
forcément qu'elle avait déjà testé
dispositif et que sans le faire exprès
nous avions dû lui demander de les
refaire c'était sa première fois était
juste une personne hors norme
le plus intéressant lors des tests puis
les échanges qui suivaient les voyants
nous demandait s'il faisait un meilleur
score que les autres les non voyants ont
posé énormément de questions sur la
suite du projet ces essais sont des jeux
pour les voyants et pour les non voyants
c'est un nouvel espoir pour leur avenir
nous sommes aussi en train de nous
rendre compte que le dispositif permet
d'explorer l'incroyable capacité de
notre cerveau nous échangeons avec des
chercheurs du cnrs pour mieux comprendre
les procédés d'apprentissage notre
conviction est qu'à terme le dispositif
ne sera pas plus dérangeant que portait
une paire de lunettes et un bracelet
le dispositif ne remplacera pas la vue
points
voyant les aidera dans leur vie de tous
les jours comme le dial hummer bonisseur
de la bath la vague ne voit pas il
ressent paradoxalement il voit le chat
ses moustaches le dauphin peut-être son
sonar sommes persuadés que l'homme peut
se doter d'un sixième sens merci à vous
[Applaudissements]